nous sommes en direct avec david
rigoulet roze rédacteur en chef de la
revue aurions stratégique et gérard
vespière fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté bonsoir messieurs et
merci d'être avec nous ce soir sur rtl
france la prise de kaboul est ce que
c'est une question de jours voire
d'heures est ce que les talibans peuvent
s'emparer du pouvoir par la force
vis-à-vis de la population afghane et
vis-à-vis aussi la communauté
internationale j'ai un vestiaire
c'est une décision politique à prendre
part à la fois par le pouvoir afghan par
l'armée afghane et par une composante
aussi très importante que constitue donc
les seigneurs de la guerre les milices
dans l'est dans les régions
que voit-on depuis quelques jours et
bien effectivement il y a pas de
décision de créer et je peux je pèse mes
mots une situation de guerre civile
parce que c'est là vraiment la
problématique centrale du pouvoir afghan
vis-à-vis de sa population parce que
jusqu'à présent il a subi les attaques
des talibans
depuis des années la merguez il
répondait mais il ya eu un basculement
stratégique à partir du moment où les
afghans au ont pris les talibans pendant
auprès des positions dans les villes
maintenant ils sont visibles maintenant
ils tiennent dépôts est un des
carrefours y tiennent des installations
militaires donc ils peuvent subir des
fera parce qu'ils sont sur la défensive
mais cette décision là n'est pas prise
car ce serait effectivement le
déclenchement d'une guerre civile et
c'est une décision vraiment lourde de
sens et on voit bien d'ailleurs que par
exemple les deux plus récents le
seigneur de la guerre
aussi bien du côté des rates que de
vasari charité bien n'ont pas pris à la
décision d'affronter les talibans pour
conserver bien sûr peut-être aussi leur
pré carré mais en tout cas de ne pas
créer vie réparable d'une guerre civile
car c'est là le grand carrefour
politique à franchir ou pas
risque aussi l'isolément international
david rigaud l'hérault s'il prônait
kaboul par la force est ce que c'est
quelque chose auquel les talibans sont
sensibles
je dirais que c'est l'ennemi si la seule
carte qui restent ou aux occidentaux en
général aux américains particulier c'est
la question fut très sain si
effectivement la reconnaissance
d'un éventuel nouvel émirat islamique
puisque on a vu que la stratégie de
communication des talibans étaient
étaient fortement axées sus te ment sur
7 la clé la question de leur crédibilité
vis-à-vis de l'international que ce soit
vis-à-vis des russes des chinois et donc
de ce qu'on appelle nous la colle aux
métiers l'international ce qui est un
peu différent par rapport à la situation
des années 90 où manifestement à
l'époque c'était le cadet de leurs
soucis c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et
donc c'est le seul moyen de pression
relatif qui demeure d'ailleurs les
allemands ont dit qu'il supprimerait
tout les toutes les allocations de fonds
justement pour aider l'afghanistan et
josette borel a dit le représentant
justement de de bruxelles des européens
a dit que si si il y avait une prise par
la force et s'il y'avait l'établissement
de de la charia comme on peut le
craindre ça vous portez créé toute forme
de reconnaissance si les taliban
parvenait à prendre le contrôle de tout
le pays c'est je dirais que c'est là le
seul la seule carte mais le problème
c'est que ces relative parce que les
talibans joue aussi sur les divisions
des membres du conseil de sécurité ils
ont discuté avec les russes d'un côté et
surtout les chinois de l'autre et ils
savent très bien instrumentaliser les
divisions de cette communauté
internationale leur profil
comment est ce qu'on explique leur
avance est si rapide elle a commencé
cette offensive au mois de mai en
quelques semaines ils sont emparés d'une
bonne partie de l'afghanistan gérard
vespière de quels soutiens ce qu'il
bénéficie
quel financement certains gouverneurs de
région aussi leur ont pour ainsi dire
laisser les clés
du pouvoir c'est aussi le résultat d'une
certaine lassitude de la pohdh de la
population afghane mais aussi des
combattants vis-à-vis du pouvoir afghan
en place
je crois que il y avait déjà une
mainmise dans les provinces n'est ce pas
dans la les talibans ils ont annoncé il
ya quelques semaines
contrôlez 85% de la surface du pays je
crois qu'on est plutôt dans les dents
les 60% et ça représente peu près 50% de
la population parce que les villes bien
sûr pèse il ya 5 millions d'habitants à
kaboul mais cela veut pas dire que en
ayant 50 % ils ont déjà une avancée
exceptionnelle et je crois que à partir
du moment où il n'y a pas de résistance
armée en face d'eux et et bien leur
avance et devient relativement facile
bon et on a bien vu du côté des rapts et
bien il y a aussi une influence
iranienne
le responsable de cette région est bien
à passer à séjourner en iran n'est ce
pas et s'il y avait des conflits à
l'intérieur de l'iran entre les talibans
les anti talibans pour faire court et
bien il y aurait des réfugiés hors
l'iran a déjà huit cent mille réfugiés
afghans sur son territoire donc là aussi
il y à des incitations à ne pas franchir
ce pas donc il y a avec le contrôle de
50% à peu près de la population des
capacités financières qui vont et qui
sont à l'échelle de cette de ce contrôle
de situation avant les dernières étapes
du retrait américain qui sont
aujourd'hui david rigaud les roses les
talibans qui combattent les forces
régulières en gagnent ils sont issus de
la population en gare ils viennent de
l'étranger
historiquement il ya un mouvement qui
effectivement est apparu a cédé 90 qui
étaient calées s'est structuré par les
services secrets pakistanais à l'époque
et qui avait arrêté là car si d'ailleurs
ce qu'ils avaient expliqué leur le
relatif succès delà de la prise rapide
des taliban à l'époque heures on est la
situation n'est pas tout à fait la même
aujourd'hui
c'est il s'agit pas tout à fait non plus
des mêmes même si sur le fond
l'idéologie et est inchangé c'est la
forme qui a beaucoup évolué ils ont fait
des progrès en termes de communication
incontestablement mais sur le fond rien
n'a changé en revanche sur le plan
opérationnel des choses ont changé et
d'être là des questions se posent
d'abord effectivement d'un encadrement
d'une aide extérieure qui est posée de
certains soutiens de pays limitrophes à
leur profit et puis il ya la
constitution de on l'a vu dans la prise
des vilains yahvé stratégie assez
élaboré pour prendre à contre-pied les
forces gouvernementales d'abord en
prenant le contrôle du nord où il n'y a
pas une majorité de pachtounes sont
issus la plupart des aliments
qui sont plutôt au sud et batum il se
trouve que les talibans ont mis en place
aussi un certain nombre d'unités
notamment sarah quita kaki sur des
troupes de choc qui ont été formés de
manière très efficace et qui ont fait la
différence dans l'assaut des villes et
ce qui a probablement surpris l'armée
gouvernementale qui est a été
démoralisés par les succès rapides d'une
forme blitz est ce qui explique
aujourd'hui la situation est telle qu'on
la connaît sur le terrain il pourrait
être un peu triviale investir cette
situation aujourd'hui c'est la faute aux
états unis joe biden dit ne pas
regretter le retrait des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan qui malgré
tout beau devrait être effective fin
août dans quelques semaines
je vais répondre à votre question juste
avant j'aurais revenir ceux ci vient
d'être dit il n'y a pas de bleach parce
que un blitz veut dire une guerre rapide
or il n'ya pas vrai véritablement
d'affrontements armés dure qui dure des
jours des semaines entre l'armée
afghanes et les talibans cessent pas
donc voilà c'est plutôt à une décision
il n'est pas prise d' affronter
militairement les talibans qui n'a pas
été pris cette décision et peut-être
qu'il ne sera pas reprise du tout donc
voilà vraiment l'écho de la situation et
leur crème et étudiants les états unis
oui le retrait américain voyez vous il
faut remonter à l'époque de barack obama
qui avait créé ce qui s'appelle en
anglais a search dire une augmentation
des effectifs qui sont montés jusqu'à
130 mille hommes et depuis donc il y a
eu un retrait systématique des forces
armées américaines donc on est parti de
130000 on va arriver à zéro houllier sur
plusieurs années donc il y avait
vraiment un cheminement américains de se
désengager progressivement et finalement
totalement de cette situation parce que
une guerre de guérilla une guerre
idéologique de guérilla et bien est
infiniment difficile à contrôler et à
maintenir impossible à gagner l'union
soviétique on a fait l'expérience les
etats unis en ont fait l'expérience
aussi pour au vietnam donc voilà qu'on
nous avait une population déterminée
qui ne veut pas de votre présence et de
votre façon de gérer un pays eh bien les
décisions arrive à ce que nous avons
sous les yeux actuellement les états
unis qui vont envoyer trois mille
soldats à kaboul pour évacuer leurs
diplomates et leurs ressortissants les
états unis ce sont des formes denrées
engagement militaire quel est votre
regard david rigaud les roses
c'est pas un réel engagement militaire
c'est plutôt le signe d'une accélération
d'un débat qu hélas effectivement toute
la presse américaine s'est fait l'écho
d'image
douloureuse un rôle qui renvoie à saïgon
en 75 parce que on dit même qu'il se dit
même d'après la presse américaine que
l'administration et ses rennes négocier
avec avec les talibans pour qu'ils aient
pas d'assaut sur non pas ce n'est pas la
capitale à proprement parler mais sur
l'ambassade américaine donc c'est dire à
quel point on est arrivé aujourd'hui et
ça va poser un problème en terme de
crédibilité zerguine débâcle morale mais
il ya une défaite stratégique débâcle
morale incontestablement mais sur le
plan stratégique
ça va être comme 75 d'ailleurs saigon il
y aura un coût à long terme et la va se
poser justement la question du bilan par
rapport à d'autres pays qui sont des
compétiteurs stratégiques notamment la
chine qui regarde très attentivement
cette situation parce que elle espère en
tirer évidemment un profit à moyen et à
long terme avec le départ américain
gerald espère est ce que vous direz que
la vraie l'afghanistan va s'enliser dans
le chaos malgré les déclarations de
l'otan des états unis de londres aussi
qu'ils promettent de ne pas laisser
tomber le gouvernement afghan
le chaos je n'espère pas pour une
population de 35 millions d'habitants un
espace ça vraiment catastrophique à mais
des difficultés oui et toute la
communauté internationale redoute un
pouvoir radical est donc un émirat
islamique au co au coeur de l'asie n'est
ce pas et donc vous avez une crainte de
la rue si vous avez avec une liasse
portion de cette population musulmane à
vous avez une crainte de l'iran avec
effectivement des réfugiés en on vous
avait une crainte de la chine parce que
bon il ya quand même le problème
ouïgours alors on peut mettre le
problème ouigours sous le tapis mais à
un moment idéologiquement il serait
normal que les talibans se soucie de la
situation des musulmans en chine donc
vraiment tout le monde dans la
communauté internationale est vent
debout contre un pouvoir radicale
des talibans à kaboul
contre la présence des talibans
un gouvernement afghan mais cela les
talibans l'envol pas merci beaucoup
c'est la fin de ce débat merci à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à cet échange
d'un gérard vesper fondateurs du web
magazine le monde décrypté d'avs des
rigoles et rose rédacteur en chef de la
revue aurions stratégique